hi everyone my name is sai venom and I'm
with the IBM cloud team today let's talk
about Cloud Foundry an open source
platform as-a-service
now Cloud Foundry is a platform in the
truest sense of the word and that
enables you to focus on cloud native
application development and really puts
a focus on developer experience that's
every step of the way from developing
the app testing it and moving it all the
way into production and automating all
of those flows to make it really easy
for a developer to get started now
there's a lot of technologies out there
for doing cloud native transformation
modernization but let's see where Cloud
Foundry fits in with some of those other
capabilities we've got a few things
sketched out here but we'll get started
from the bottom with bare-bones
physical infrastructure now I'd say that
most companies that are using physical
right now are really just kind of
getting started or maybe have legacy
applications so they're they're looking
to move into the cloud next up we've got
VMs now VMs continue to be very popular
they're a great way to package up
applications but with the growth of
container technology companies are
starting to see the advantage and a more
agile workflow by taking advantage of
containers and something like kubernetes
to manage and orchestrate them now
building on top of that here's where
cloud foundry comes in so cloud foundry
as I mentioned has a very developer
focused approach so from every step of
the way they focus on the developer
experience and I think one of the
biggest detractors or most difficult
things for a company to get started with
cloud native is changing the culture
within their company from the inside out
from the developer level up and with
Cloud Foundry your developers can truly
focus on what matters
development and they can just assume
that the infrastructure works as
important as it is the end of the day
developers don't want to focus on
infrastructure they just want to expect
that things are running smoothly and
that same kind of ideologies applies top
of the stack here with serverless
technology where developers focus on
writing just functions even less than
just applique
now as we go down in the stack we have
control so you get more control when
you're working with VMs or kubernetes on
exactly how your app is deployed but
what if your developers simply don't
care what if they have applications that
they want to run and don't care how the
infrastructure looks and they don't care
how it's deployed they just want a
running application well that's where
you get the advantages of taking
advantage of something like cloud
foundry and server lists you get
ease-of-use
as well as speed now let's actually take
this now that we have the understanding
of where cloud foundry fits in and say
we have a legacy application and let's
build that out and see how it fits in to
broader cloud stack so we'll say over
here that we have a front-end
application and that in turn works with
a back-end let's say there's a legacy
application with you know a lot of
restrictions on security networking and
how it runs and that kind of thing and
that's kind of responsible for
communicating with an old-school
database now we want to take this
application let's say we want to make a
cloud native take advantage of a
cloud-based platform so the first thing
our developers will do without
understanding anything about the
infrastructure they'll start with let's
say the front-end and modernizing it
let's say they want to use something
like react take advantage of nodejs to
create an all new application taking
advantage of that front-end piece and
we're going to move that into the cloud
so taking advantage of simply the the
dev tools that are available through
node.js and react in those capabilities
they create a front-end application say
that's version 2 now so far along that
path the developers had no reason to
have to understand the underlying
infrastructure they created that
application and next let's say they've
used a CLI tool so this is where cloud
foundry comes in they use the CF tool
to deploy that application into the
cloud now this is where the the first
core tenets of cloud foundry comes in
and it's the fact that it's a polyglot
environment this means you can take
applications written in a number of
different languages running on any
platform and CF has something called
build packs that'll take them and
automate all of the kind of building and
deploying processes so using CF and any
kind of language any application they
can now deploy this into the cloud so
let's say that over here this is the
cloud side they've taken CF and now they
have an application running for that
front-end app let's take it a step back
and build out that infrastructure from
the ground up to see exactly what
happened to take that application and to
get and running so at the bottom here we
have the cloud infrastructure building
on top of that we have the Cloud Foundry
technology that actually is able to take
this app and run it as a container in
one of these say there are VMs so here
we have Diego the Cloud Foundry tech as
well as garden which is remarkably
similar to something like docker or
container runtimes it's the container
technology that Cloud Foundry used so
long before docker was popular back in
so using these technologies cloud
foundry takes the SAP and runs it and
schedules it within a VM so here we have
our it's called the CF aar Cloud Foundry
application runtime environment the
Diego and garden is kind of responsible
for scheduling and managing so we've
managed to figure out half of the puzzle
here let's take it a step further that
back-end out with those networking and
security considerations let's say that
we care about how it's deployed we don't
want it to be automatic we do care about
the networking and storage
considerations we want to run it in a
containerized way we don't want to go in
there and change any code so we want to
use something like kubernetes so let's
say we take this back-end application
and could
in arise it so now it's running as a
container maybe in a container image so
we want to deploy this application of
kubernetes right so we'll use a CF tool
or rather a CLI tool and this time is
going to be cube CTL and we want to
deploy this into the same cloud now you
might think we're out of luck because
we're taking advantage of CF and Diego
and garden but actually there's a new
project the compound release called
project ireenie that enables you to swap
out that underlying infrastructure the
Diego and garden portion and instead
take advantage of kubernetes that means
that we can continue to use those tools
that cube CTL + CF together in the same
environment your operations teams would
manage this side of the puzzle to make
sure everything works seamlessly but
your dev team has no impact for their CF
apps because they don't really need to
care about what's powering it and for
the apps that need to be run in
kubernetes they can continue to use that
same architecture so using cube CTL here
we can take that back-end application
and run it as a container within the
same environment and so essentially what
we end up with here is the ability to do
not only CF application runtime kind of
based environment but also kubernetes
together and that actually brings me to
my second point here is the fact that
cloud foundry is interoperable now this
is very important because essentially
the fact that it's interoperable means
although the newest fad and technologies
are changing over the years growth of
things like docker and kubernetes cloud
foundry keeps the same familiar
developer experience for their users but
at the same time due to their open
nature and open source and the fact that
they're keeping up with the latest
technologies they have support for
kubernetes underneath the covers and so
this is very core for enabling our users
to kind of avoid lender lock-in to take
of the latest and greatest technologies
and that kind of brings me to my last
point is that Cloud Foundry is open it's
open source and it has an open
governance model it's actually the CF
foundation IBM it's a core part of it
and we do make contributions to CF and
it's a core part of our cloud strategy
as well so we have kind of a lot of
contributions that we make to help make
this run smoothly in our cloud as well
say that's a core part of the open
philosophy that powers Cloud Foundry
it's the fact that anyone can make
contributions and features it's
completely open-source and the second
thing I want to mention on that front is
the fact that there's an open service
broker API meaning third party services
from any kind of contributor can be
listed in in something called a
marketplace allowing Cloud Foundry users
to very easily integrate with those
third party services take an advantage
of an open service broker API so let's
say these three core tenants and kind of
what we talked about today Cloud Foundry
is truly kind of one of those really
powerful platforms enabling you to focus
on cloud native application development
and allows you to avoid things like
vendor lock-in and stay up-to-date with
the latest technologies with things like
project ireenie allowing you to base all
of these familiar applications on
kubernetes technology thanks for joining
me for this quick overview of Cloud
Foundry as always you can get started
with the free trial on IBM cloud and you
can find a link for that below if you
like this video or you want to see more
videos like this in the future be sure
to drop a like and subscribe and stay
tuned thank you